PList and JSON or
JSON files are one of those concepts
that takes practice to fully grasp.
In this playground I've demonstrated
some really practical examples for
using each.
But before we look at the code
let's take a look at some PList and
JSON files.
So, I'm going to go over here
to the resources folder.
Let's start by looking
at the students.p list.
So, if we look here at the top, we
notice that this contains an array, and
within the array we have dictionaries.
Now for each dictionary,
we have key value pairs representing
some things related to students.
So we have a key name that
maps to a String value,
in this case the value is Shawn.
We have an H key that maps to
a number value, in this case 57.
And we have School key that
maps to another String,
in this case the University of Maryland.
Each of these dictionaries could easily
be converted into a simple struct.
That's what this first
code example does.
So here at the top of the file we define
the student struct with the name, and
age, and school.
These next lines of code are critical.
This line here creates a path
represented as a URL that tells us
where the student's plist is located.
Then this next line of code takes that
path, again that's represented as a URL,
and loads it into an array and
we're calling this the student array.
Now some of the code going on
here you haven't quite seen yet
but you could probably make sense of it.
It uses classes which
are similar to Strucs and
they have their own functions like
URL for Resource that belong to them.
We'll get to classes later.
For now, I just want to focus on the
task at hand which is working with plist
and jsondata.
Now another thing I want to know is
the reason that we're loading this into
an array instead of maybe a dictionary.
Is if we go back to the plist file,
we can see here at the top that the root
of this plist file is an array,
and not a dictionary.
So that's key.
In the next lines of code we loop
through the students array and
we check for those key value pairs,
name, age, and school.
And if each of those
key value pairs exist,
then we create a student struct and we
append it to our studentStructs array.
Then at the bottom I have this simple
use case where we print some information
about each student.
Now this printing is pretty trivial, but
imagine if this student data was loaded
from the p list file into the student
structs, and then we displayed in
some slick looking user interface.
Now that would be pretty sweet.
You'll start building towards doing
things like this as you start building
apps from scratch.